today I want to talk about why potassium
makes you energetic and why if you're
deficient you become fatigued
now this topic is quite fascinating
because it relates to a pump in all of
your cells of the body called the sodium
potassium pump and I'm going to dive in
a little bit just to explain what that
is and why that is so significant it has
to do with this out of all the energy
that your body uses to digest to grow
hair to create motion with muscles and
the energy it takes to run all the
enzymes this little sodium pump takes
the lion's share of energy nearly 30
percent of all the energy that is
utilized from your body from the food
that you consume is allocated this one
little pump
of course these pumps are in all the
cells but it's interesting that your
body is giving that much energy to this
one specific function and many people
don't really even know what it is
they've never even heard about it before
now the definition of the word pump is
slightly different than the sump pump
that you have in your basement it's a
biological definition the definition of
this pump is a mechanism for the
movement of electrolytes through the
cell membrane so you have this membrane
this cell wall which is very very thin
it's like two molecules thick and
electrolytes are electrically charged
chemicals or in this case electrically
charged minerals and we're talking about
sodium and potassium
very simply the main goal of this pump
is to keep sodium going out and
potassium going in in other words to
keep the potassium inside the cell and
keep the sodium outside the cell that's
its goal now when you have different
concentrations of electrically charged
minerals inside the cell versus outside
the cell you basically create a battery
okay so the purpose of the sodium
potassium pump is to maintain electrical
charge so that cell can act as a battery
all right so now the question is what is
the significance of having your cell
maintain electrical charge what is it
actually doing and that's going to be
the next topic it has everything to do
with four things primarily there's other
things but the four primary functions
are this to support neurons in helping
the nerves transmit signals ok
communication through the body and I'm
talking about all the nerves including
nerves in your brain the central nervous
system also to work with calcium to help
the muscles contract and relax so we
have nerve and we have muscle function
also to help the cell establish the
correct pH and help maintain fluid
control as you know if there's a problem
with sodium for example if it's you're
retaining too much sodium you're gonna
actually the cells are gonna swell too
much right so the balance of potassium
and sodium is very very important and to
maintain the proper volume of fluid
through the body now here's what happens
when you're low in potassium and by the
way you also need sodium for this pump
to work too but you need four times as
much potassium than sodium and if we
look at sodium versus potassium more
people are deficient in potassium and
then they are sodium so what happens
when you're low in potassium
well the nerves suffer you start getting
brain fog why because we're talking
about the nerves in your brain also you
can get slow reflexes tingling in the
nerves numbness in the nerves
abnormal heart rhythm because the sodium
potassium pump is located in the
pacemaker of the heart which controls
the rhythm of the heart so it affects
the brain as a brain fog or you're going
to have motor nerve problems too the
muscle which could affect the ability to
move and and actually maintain a certain
motion for a period of time so you might
get tired a lot faster because you just
don't have the sodium potassium pump
working effectively throughout the
entire body all right number two has to
do with the ability for the muscles to
contract and relax
I can show up in cramps that can show up
in fatigue as an muscle fatigue it can
show up in muscle aches muscle stiffness
tremors constipation because your colon
is actually smooth muscle and that could
be a problem
weakness in general and high blood
pressure because your arteries have a
certain type of muscle that can be
dysfunctional all right and then we have
pH if you're deficient in potassium the
body has a tendency to be more acid and
then fluid control if there is a
potassium deficiency you can get
swelling in the body I mean how many
people have way too much sodium versus
potassium and their ankles are just
swollen when you consume foods higher in
potassium swelling goes away so I just
wanted to show you the the connection
between what this sodium potassium pump
controls and the effects that it can
create if it if you're missing the
actual raw material that makes up that
pump now let's go into this last part
right here how do people become
deficient in potassium dietary they
don't consume enough foods high in
potassium the foods that have the most
potassium would be leafy greens or
avocados so people just don't consume
enough you'd have to consume seven to
ten cups of salad or vegetables to get
close to your RTA's which is 4700 and
the reason to bringing this up is
because potassium is the hardest to get
it's very easy to consume sodium but
it's not as easy to get potassium from
your diet okay if you're in diuretics
that could cause a potassium deficiency
vomiting diarrhea can deplete you a
potassium if you're a diabetic and you
have high insulin that can create a
potassium deficiency if you consume
sugar who are you doing a high carb diet
that will deplete potassium as well the
more stress you go through the more
injury you have the more trauma the more
the body will dump potassium and lastly
I wanted to talk about this one last
thing keto what that's right going on a
ketogenic diet can cause your body to
require more potassium why because when
you go on a ketogenic diet and you lower
your carbs and you don't need the
quantity of storage sugar anymore sugar
actually stores water or fluid so one
sugar molecule will store almost three
molecules of water so basically the more
sugar you consume the more glycogen you
have the more fluid that you're
retaining like you're a sponge of fluid
so when we cut down the carbs you lose
the fluid and because these two minerals
sodium-potassium work together you're
gonna lose not just sodium but you're
gonna lose potassium you're gonna end up
with the lower amount of potassium if
you're already deficient in potassium
you're gonna be even more deficient and
this is why people get the keto fatigued
this is why they might get cramps this
is why they might get side effects when
they go on a ketogenic diet but not if
they're doing the healthy version of
keto that I recommend which is basically
consuming foods that give you more of
the nutrients that you need potassium is
important the B vitamins a little bit
more sea salt would be very beneficial
so if you started the ketogenic diet and
you feel tired and you feel weak all you
have to do is beef up no pun intended
the potassium and some sodium and that
should go away pretty quick all right so
that was a very long explanation of why
potassium makes you energetic but I
think it was important and I think it's
actually incredibly interesting so
thanks for watching so if you want more
knowledge on how to create a healthy
body subscribe now and get daily
notifications